[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he is brian kelly the lsu head coach
joining us on the program good morning
coach congratulations how do you feel
i'm a little tired right now but i'm
i've got chicory in my coffee down here
in louisiana and it tastes really good
well you got a lot to get used to down
there food wise um and and you're not a
po boy after uh the contract details
were released there so uh
congratulations on that what does lsu
give you that notre dame could not give
you any more
well i don't know if it wasn't it really
didn't have anything to do with what
notre dame couldn't give me as much as
another opportunity another challenge to
come down in the sec
you know to play in you know obviously
arguably the best conference
in the country um and and the resources
here are incredible uh so
you know i just think another another
opportunity uh one where
you're going to be challenged week in
and week out amongst the best and
i was at that time in my career that i
was i was looking for that new challenge
band and um i'm really excited my
family's excited uh we haven't been in
this part of the country and uh we're
looking forward to it our first day in
in louisiana was yesterday and um
it's pretty exciting when did you start
looking for that next challenge
i don't think you
you know you're so focused on your team
you know um
that that my focus was on my guys at
notre dame uh so
um i don't know that there was
ever a you know wandering eye
at all um
but you know we're curious we're coaches
right we're always looking for you know
that um that next challenge and you know
when the season was over and and um
you know things started to move quickly
this opportunity presented itself and um
that's why we're here where we are right
now
all right help me out with this just
understanding that you know there's
recruiting limitations uh with notre
dame admissions
uh you know school discipline those kind
of things rick newheisel was with us
last hour and he said you know those are
hurdles at notre dame with lsu
you don't have those hurdles
uh how important is that that you can go
after players and not sit there and wait
to see if somebody's going to go we'll
give you the green light to get somebody
in
well i think each school has
distinctions right i mean the
distinctions of notre dame are real and
and they are um
they are incredible but i think that lsu
has distinctions as well in terms of its
geographical base its ability to recruit
um you know the state of louisiana um as
i mentioned to you before the you know
the the facilities here uh for football
um
so
you know i don't think it's that you
know one's
you know the negative over the positive
as much as you know we did
we did quite well obviously at notre
dame um
you know giving given who notre dame is
and the distinctions notre dame had we
had five consecutive ten plus winning
seasons only alabama and notre dame did
that
and so
those distinctions
were still ones that were
easily accomplished that team is is so
good i believe that they can be in in
the college football players three out
of the last four years
here at lsu you've got other
distinctions and i mentioned of
geographics facilities
incredible fan base national
championship just a couple years ago so
all those things are real here too as
well
uh is there a tactful way to say goodbye
never it's it's uh it's always difficult
because of
you know
things get leaked and they get out to
the media before you can actually get in
front of your guys i did the best i
could i was on the road recruiting um
and and things got you know out to the
media before but i i was able to send a
note to my guys and then get in front of
them yesterday at 7 00 am and and tell
them i love them um i love my guys um
and
they know i love them and
i think they're one of the best four
teams in the country and um
they deserve to play in the college
football playoffs yeah i wondered how
important it was to be the
all-time leader in victories at notre
dame which you did this season and then
at age 60 you know you might look around
and go
i've done uh i've left notre dame in
good hands you know 12 years in where we
are and who we are and what we are
that i can be selfish and do something
for myself
how
how accurate is that
well i can tell you that that the charge
that i had was to modernize notre dame
football bring it back to relevance and
consistency as one of the top programs
in the country and we check all those
boxes i was never going to notre dame to
be the all-time winningest coach that
kind of happened along the way you know
our process was about you know uh
graduating champions and we did that and
you know the outcomes were what they
were but that was never my intent it was
to modernize the college the the
football program which we did with
infrastructure and improvements um
it was certainly about consistency in
performance and in graduating you know
our football players and all of those
things
were accomplished and um
you know i didn't just wake up one day
and say oh i've done all this and kind
of you know said all right it's time to
move on but i saw this as an incredible
opportunity and um excited about the the
next chapter he's lsu head coach brian
kelly when's the first time lsu reached
out to your representatives
uh
you know
my my uh my
agent um
handles all that stuff and so i couldn't
tell you exactly dan because he doesn't
he doesn't keep me in the loop on all
these things i think he he kind of calls
me when he thinks the time is right so
it was after you know obviously um
our last game and and we
we struck a deal pretty quickly did usc
reach out at any point
you know i think i think there was a lot
of interest from other schools but um
again you know i think that for me
um
you know it was let's get through the
season and once we did we kind of
measured what was the best situation for
me
if you were ranked third right now coach
would you still be in louisiana
oh
i don't know dan you know those those
are those are tough questions you know
i mean i'm i'm a pretty honest guy and
and
would tell you but i i those those are
so hard to
you know to answer relative to what i've
had done something different in in that
situation and i i really couldn't tell
you to be honest with you um
because it's not the case um
but but i i really couldn't answer that
question what's the status of your
assistant coaches at notre dame
yeah you know so you know we're gonna
hire the best coaches right you know i
great coaches at notre dame uh we can
hire great coaches here at lsu so um
you know they're employed right now at
notre dame and um you know certainly we
have to be sensitive to that fact other
guys that
would i love to have some of those guys
join me here absolutely but we have to
go through the right process um and you
know that's that's going to be a fluid
situation
is that part of your exit with notre
dame that you can't poach your assistant
coaches
no
no okay i mean
look i mean at the end of the day you're
not going to do something that is
morally or ethically
um
you know not sound um
and you're going to work with the
university that you just left but like i
said there's there's there's good
coaches here that i want to talk to
there's there's certainly great coaches
that i work with at notre dame but we're
going to do it the right way
what happens to all your notre dame gear
i was going to send some of it to you
i'd like that but i i've slimmed down a
little but you're so skinny i don't know
you probably need a schmedium right well
i got fritzy and fritzy i'm sure will be
able to uh fit into
you can take some of my xls yeah
now do you just leave everything did you
take any notre dame gear
um we haven't gotten a chance to do that
yet um this has been kind of a whirlwind
kind of deal um so
we haven't really gotten a chance to
even get back to the um
you know the packing of um my damn
patrick trophy
so
yeah i haven't got that packed yet okay
were you building a house what happens
now were you building a house on campus
i built it yeah it's built it's done are
you interested
does that go to luke fickle when he
comes in
if he if
if he opens up his pocketbook i heard i
heard he's got to pay
you know that midwestern money they
gotta spend
are you in a hotel in louisiana
yeah i'm on the on-campus uh hotel um
and uh
great accommodations and um
plenty of zippo potato chips
what is the most surreal moment of the
last
72 hours
uh
you know i just think the the the whole
thing you know from
getting off a flag yesterday at 5 30 a.m
from the west coast talking to the team
getting back on the flight talking to
the team it's just the the continuation
of um
closure to starting a new um it's it's
just like
one
one continuous
moment in time and you just don't have a
chance to take a breath okay wait a
minute you're recruiting in la
yesterday
yes
okay how does that work that you're
recruiting and then do you get on the
plane and find out that you're
taking over
yes
yes
yeah this is crazy so you're recruiting
as notre dame's head coach get on a
plane
in route back to south bend
you find out that this deal has been
solidified
yes sir wow
true story
was who was on the plane with you
uh my my uh attorney
that's smart
that's smart well okay
that would be the heads up though if
your attorney is on the flight coach
that's not your normal recruiting trip
no i know but we picked him up at the
airport because it already was starting
to leak out
oh god
so you land and all of a sudden you're
no longer notre dame's head coach
and now you have to resign
oh my god
and then what an hour and a half later
you get your kids together
yes yeah we had sent out attacks before
we left orange county and then
and let them know that we would have a 7
a.m team meeting did you follow up with
the recruits to say hey
if you're not interested in notre dame
uh you can join me in lsu
of course not dan of course not
what is this
i'm talking to judge judy now i would do
that
wait i mean are you kidding me that's
lincoln riley's bringing players who
decommitted to
oklahoma well lincoln lincoln can do
what lincoln wants to do brian kell is
going to do what he does
all right
uh what's planned for the rest of the
day
we're going to do some photo shoots with
the family
i'm going to try to find some temporary
housing
um and then i'm going to meet with a
number of
smaller
smaller media types not the power
brokers like you oh okay
all right well congratulations and uh
we'll stay in touch
all right great talking to you as always
that's brian kelly
former notre dame head coach